Avec nous : Docteur Horacio
Arruda, directeur national
de la santé publique du Québec.
Dr Arruda, bonsoir.- Bonsoir, M.
- Alors, 20. Pourquoi pas 30,
pourquoi pas 15, pourquoi pas
35? Comment ça va fonctionner?
Quand le premier ministre
a dit publiquement 20 à 25,
ça vous donnait quand même
un cadre, non? Comment ça va
marcher?
- Écoutez, il faut comprendre
qu'il n'y a pas d'article
scientifique qui va vous
dire qu'avec la situation
épidémiologique du Québec,
le chiffre à retenir
est 23, 24 ou 26.
Moi, je tiens à vous dire
que le premier ministre aurait
pu dire 100, 10, 13, l'analyse
que j'ai faite est en fonction
de ce qui se passe comme
épidémiologie actuellement
au Québec, de la non-présence
du variant Omicron, mais
qui va peut-être venir.
.c. REC de Judith
Avec nous : Docteur Horacio
Et l'année dernière,
il y avait aucun rassemblement
permis à la maison pour Noël.
Et l'année dernière,
il y avait aucun rassemblement
permis à la maison pour Noël.
Là, on passe... il y a 10
actuellement récemment,
et on vec 20, c'est
un chiffre qui est raisonnable
par rapport à l'augmentation
des contacts, mais aussi pour
permettre à certaines familles
de pouvoir se rassembler.
avez, il n'y a pas
de modèle mathématique clair
par rapport à ça, mais je tiens
à dire aussi, cependant,
que j'ai dit qu'on peut
aller jusqu'à 20 chez des...ches
obligé d'aller jusqu'à 20.
Si vous avez des craintes
importantes, parce qu'il y a
quand même du virus qui circule
même parmi les gens vaccinés,
on peut aller à moindrement
jusqu'à ça. Mais jusqu'à 20,
on pense que c'est raisonnable.
- Donc, vous dites que ça n'a
rien à voir quand le premier
ministre du Québec dit la
semaine dernière qu'il aimerait
que ce soit 20 à 25 parce
qu'on veut que les gens passent
un beau Noël. Vous dites que
vous avez fait abstraction de
ça, mais que vouquandquandquandd
même au même résultat.
- Écoutez, il faut comprendre
que les chiffres... c'est sûr
qu'on allait pas aller à 100.
Personne, actuellement, on sait
que les rassemblements privés
sont une hausse importante.
Très honnêtement, moi, dans mon
analyse, on aurait pu aller à
10, ce qui aurait été peut-être
moins acceptable pour les
Québécois qui ont fait l'effort
de se faire vacciner. On aurait
pu aller à 30 ou 40. M
trouve que 20 est un bon chiffre
pour permettre à la fois parce
qu'on sait qu'ili vonti vonti vt
aller à 25 ou 30, pour permettre
de le faire. L'autre élément que
je tiens à met qui est
important pour moi, c'est que
les gens non-vaccinés, je vais
vous dire, si jeenir
trois ou quatre cas de mortalité
ou 10 ou 15 cas de gens qui vont
aux soins intensifs, je leur
faire vacciner
dès maintenant.
- Dr Arruda, je vais vous
montrer un tableau aujourd'hui
par rapport à il y a un an
à la même date à peu près.
Le nombre de cas... vous allez
voir apparaître, donc le nombre
ier, 1577
et cette année, 1234.
Donc, il y en avait plus l'an
r, mais ilr, mais ilr, mais ilru
près le même nombre. Beaucoup
moins de décès cette année.
Hospitalisations, c'est là
où ça n'a rien à voir, on est35t
vivre avec la COVID, c'est ça
qu'on veut dire? C'est que là,
il va y avoir un plateau
et qu'il faut vivre avecce qui s
qui va se promener?
t une très bonne question
que vous amenez. Effectivement,
il faut comprendre
qu'actuellement, on pourrait
avoir le même nombre de cas, onr
avec moins d'impact sur
lesystème de soins, et c'est ce
qui est extraordinaire. C'est ce
qu'amène la vaccination. Parceqe
prévient pas tous les cas en
termes de maladie, elle va
prévenir les complications
sévères. Vous avez tout à fait
raison dans ce contexte. Je
pense qu'on va devoir accepter
une circulation plus importante.
Par contre, les non vaccinés
actuellement, disons qu'il y en
a à peu près 650 000 au Québec,
ces gens-là, quand le virus va
les frapper, parce qu'il va les
frapper, ils vont se retrouver
à l'hôpital et aux s
intensifs. Et c'est ceux-là
qu'on veut protéger. Et c'est
ceux-là qui peuvent devenir un
impact sur le système de soins.
Cet hiver, on va probablem
avoir de la grippe, d'autres
virus respiratoires qui vont
surcharger notre système de
soins. Mais vous avez raison.
Espérons qu'avec le variantOmics
très transmissible, mais il
n'aura pas d'impact sur la
virulence ou la morbidité en
termes hospitaliers.
- Deux choses. V
les non vaccinés vont l'avoir.
Mais les non vaccinés sont quand
même de moins en moins nombreux
au Québec. Notre taux de
vaccination est très bon.
- Vous avez raison,
comparativement à d'autres pays.
Mais il reste quand même... Vous
savez, ce quelque 600 000
personnes qui sont non
vaccinées, c'est comme un genre
d'hypothèque. Le virus va les
chercher et va vouloir les
frapper. En combien de temps? À
quelle vitesse?
Mais ces gens vont se retrouver
en milieu hospitalier et ça sera
une surcharge pour les systèmes
de soins et une problématiquepo.
Se retrouvait à 50 ans aux soins
intensifs et peut-être en
mourir, c'est quelque chose qui
est inévitable grâce au vaccin.
- Omicron, vous le dîtes et
d'autres l'ont dit, il y a des
premières études qui montrent
qu'il se transmet facilement
mais qui n'est pas si dangereux.
C'est une très bonne nouvelle.
Ça apaise pas mal tout le monde.
- Tout à fait. Mais c'est clair
tre prudentre prudentre prudente
que les données vont évoluer.
Mais si ces invariants très
ais qu'il n'a
pas la virulence et n'amène pas
de problème important, et que
les gens vacciné
protection, c'est le meilleur
des scénarios.
- Merci beaucoup de nous a